so good
afternoon today uh the college adopted
the enlargement
report it is now 10 years ago that the
protest on maidan
started maidan protests where people
were shot because they wrapped
themselves into a European
flag and now 10 years later today is a
historic day because today the
commission
recommends that the council opens
accession negotiations with Ukraine and
with
mova the commission also recommends the
opening of EU accession negotiations
with Bosnian herova once the necessary
degree of compliance with the membership
criteria is
achieved and the commission recommends
that the council grants Georgia the
status of a candidate country on the
understanding that certain reform St
steps are taken let me focus on these
four
countries first on
Ukraine Ukraine continues to face
tremendous hardship and tragedy provoked
by Russia's war of aggression and yet
the ukrainians are deeply reforming
their country even as they are fighting
a war that is existential for
them weekend and um could convince
myself well over 90% of the necessary
steps that we set out last year in in
our report just to give you an idea main
progress has been achieved on the
Constitutional Justice Reform on the
selection of the High Council of Justice
the anti-corruption program progress on
anti-money money laundering important
measures to curb the oligarchs grip on
the public life New Media law and
progress on National
minorities the remaining reforms are
already on their way that's good and the
commission commends these efforts and on
this basis we have recommended today
that the council opens access accession
negotiations we also recommend that the
council adopts a negotiating framework
once Ukraine has carried out the ongoing
reforms and on that we will report then
in March
mova mova is not facing a kinetic War
but mova is the subject of constant
destabilization efforts against its
democracy it also suffers the
consequences of the war in
Ukraine mova is welcoming a large number
of Ukrainian Refugee mova is facing
disruptions and blackmail related to its
energy system but like Ukraine mova has
undertaken significant reform efforts
for example in the area of the Judiciary
it has stepped up considerably the
investigative work related to corruption
and organized crime it has made
legislative changes to fight vested
interests so here too the commission
recommends that the council opens
accession
negotiations there are some remaining
measures that have to be finished and on
this basis here too the council could
then finalize the negotiation in
framework and the commission will report
on the progress to Council in March
2024 now Bosnia and
heroa we recognize a number of positive
political and legal steps for example
the Swift entry into office of a new
Council of minister in January
2023 um the commitment of political
parties to the goal of accession have
without any doubt brought positive res
results there is progress in the fight
against organized crime money laundering
and terrorism for example but we also
note with concern the various
unconstitutional laws adopted by the
representatives of the Republica sska
entity and against this
backdrop the commission recommends to
the council the opening of accession
negotiations once the necessary degree
of criteria is achieved and here too the
commission will report to the Council on
progress by March
2024 to
Georgia here the college fully supports
the genuine aspirations of the
overwhelming majority of its
citizens
by the authorities who should engage
more with the
opposition of national
interest is needed by the government on
the 12 priorities identified last year's
before candidate status was
Grant the commission also acknowledges a
number of positive steps for
example
the personalized approach was withdrawn
and the anti-corruption bureau was set
up therefore the commission recommends
to Grant candidates status to Georgia on
the understanding that the government
takes important reform
steps now in general to
conclude enlargement is a vital policy
for the European Union and and this has
been my main message since the beginning
of my
mandate completing our Union is the call
of History it is the natural Horizon of
the European
Union the citizens of countries that
want to join our Europeans just like
those of today's Union because we all
know that
geography history and common values bind
us so completing our Union also has a
strong economic and political and
geopolitical logic we have seen if you
see the history of the last enlargement
rounds they have shown that there is an
enormous benefits both for those
countries who access the European Union
and the European Union itself basically
we all win and you can see it for the
news members there citizens and
businesses there's access to our full
freedoms access to our single Market
citizens can travel businesses have new
markets and all of this is a powerful
lever to increase prosperity and
therefore stability in these countries
but for the European Union itself the
advantages are also very clear and
impressive the expansion of our single
Market brings economy of scale for our
businesses increases our competitiveness
and therefore the strength of our single
Market Market our history of enlargement
has dented economic success
story but also if you look at the
global and
it partner just take the fact um that
the common purchase of gas being 27
makes a huge difference in the success
of this uh this field enlargement is
also an investment in our security
because integrating new members in the E
European Union Shields those new members
also from foreign interference and it
stabilizes our neighborhood
therefore in times where we see the
rules-based international order
increasingly called into
question of course a larger and stronger
European Union gives us a stronger voice
in the world so in some enlargement is a
unique opportunity both for the
countries aspiring to join the European
Union and of course for us it is a
driver for peace and prosperity that
makes our Union so special thank you
commissioner thank you very much um I
think uh I need to continue where our
president has just uh left off today we
are not only presenting you uh the
enlargement report that we do every year
but I think today we are also bringing
forward a very strong powerful response
to the assignment made also by the
European Council namely to accelerate
the enlargement process you see the
recommendations that we're making
with and never before we have seen EU
membership being such an important
driver for countries around the European
Union so I would want to highlight
other is the growth
plan which we consider to be a
completely new and bold approach to
catalyze the progress of closing the
economic and social gap between the
Western Balkans and the EU and creating
the possibility of early integration of
the region into the European Union even
before they join our uh Union
because part of our job when we uh tell
you about the reports but this time
let's focus on the as we call it the
real or the integration on the ground
meaning
how our
societies and our countries together
with our Western Balan
Partners it is a real benefit for the
both of us and it should bring the
benefit of membership already before
accession this this is also a
request made by the member states this
year but it was also our plan when we
started working back in 2020 when we
have put on the table the new
methodology for
enlargement the plan is aimed at four
things first of all to integrate the
Western ban Partners who are
interested into the Four Freedoms as
fast as they can and as as fast as they
can cope with taking on all the
obligations stemming from our
regulations and rules for that we are of
course happy to help them we are happy
to put at their disposal every tool to
make it happen but we have a request in
return and our request is that this
should also contribute largely to the
stability security and prosperity of the
region as such and this is why
we ask them to treat each other like
they are going to treat us meaning once
they are integrating themselves with the
Four Freedoms they should reciprocate
this with other partners in the western
Balkans who are also delivering on the
Four
Freedoms the other key pillar of this
plan is to help the Western Balan
Partners to accelerate the reform
process
because of course integrating yourselves
with the Four Freedoms
entails difficult complex
reforms the Western balans and this is
why we would like to engage with them
and we would like to draw up together
with
them a very downto Earth detailed plan
for
every
accelerate the progress on the ground
when it comes to into the European
Union the third element I want to raise
is of course that once they are
integrating themselves with uh our
markets of our markets and social
systems and they cannot start to close
the gap without our financial support
and this is why we are ready to do more
also there and we are ready to provide
more support to accelerate this common
work and this is why we are proposing to
the council to increase our financial
contribution in supporting the reform
agenda and provide an additional uh6
billion EUR of support
that should bring their aid intensity
levels comparable to our cohesion and
structural funds countries already by
the end of this micro U multiannual
Financial framework so all in all we are
confident that with this plan we can
help the region to raise at least
another third of
its of its uh GDP Al together from the
common regional market from our
financial contrib contributions we think
that we can really boost the region a
boost that they need and the Boost that
we need as well thank
you thank you very much we will now take
some questions
Elina thank you Eric uh news agency
interfax Ukraine Arena summer Madame
President very short question for you
when exactly we can expect that
negotiation with Ukraine start in
reality and second part of uh this
question because you know very well
situation in Ukraine on the ground what
is your opinion how long it will last I
mean negotiation thank
you so um to take the second question
first um it depends of course it's a
merit-based process so it depends on the
speed of Reform and um uh yeah change of
uh topics that are necessary in this
negotiation process but how does it
start we give today the recommendation
to open uh accession negotiations this
is very important to the council the
council then takes the political
decision we have a European Council mid
December there this will be on the table
if the council takes the political
decision to say yes the we take uh the
recommendation of the Comm Mission and
open accession negotiations the work can
start immediately it's very technical
what then starts um we have a few or
Ukraine has a few um uh reforms still if
I may say in the pipeline in the making
on their way they have to finish that
work it is explicitly uh in our
recommendation and by March we will then
report on the progress but we can start
immediately when the European Council
has given green light um in its decision
in
December thank you K
yeah yes madame vland can you clarify
the difference between recommendation to
Ukraine and mdova and the one to Bosnia
as there is not a clearcut in Bosnian
case can this be considered as
conditional recommendation or no
recommendation as at all because you
still didn't recommend opening of
accession talks thank you oh yes we
recommend um the opening um now bosnan
and herova we recommend the opening of
an accession
negotiations um once certain criterias
are met let me take a picture we open
the door very wide and we invite bosan
heroa now to to go through this door for
that of course there has to be activity
in bosnan heroa results have to be shown
but the door is now opened very wide to
welcome bosnan and heroina for the
accession talks
yeah you need to press the button on the
mic and then wait until it's R thank you
so much um Eric thank you so much for
giving me the floor and uh madame
president Mr commissioner uh first of
all I want to start with huge thank you
because it's very emotional day for us
it's historic day and I'm happy that I'm
here and I'm sharing these moments with
you uh we want candidate status and we
want to reach membership of this
organization uh can you tell us more
about the next step when should Georgia
expect opening negotiation as Ukraine
and Moldova and what are the conditions
because there will be many questions
about it and I want also to use this
opportunity and ask my second question
this week Russian occupied forces
Russian soldiers killed our Georgian
citizen in front of uh Georgian church
can you comment on this also thank you
so
much so first of all it is a day to
celebrate in Georgia indeed candidate
state
uh we say um there are still topics to
be done um homework to be done and this
is detailed out in the report and in the
recommendation but it's a big step
forward for Georgia um and this also
a majority of the people in Georgia to
join the European Union
I'm
coming the uh yes we we have followed
what has happened and of course we stand
by the territorial Integrity of Georgia
and of course this is an alarming news
that on the territory which is
controlled by the government of Georgia
something like this can happen so I
think uh we need to help Georgia to find
the perpetrator s we are standing by in
full solidarity uh with the people of
Georgia and with the government of
Georgia
opportunity from Lithuania National
radio and television in the past decade
I have a question for Madame President
in the past decade uh we've seen that EU
enlargement process has lost its
momentum and basically stopped there was
no progress how the commission will
ensure that this time the same story
won't happen again that the momentum
that appears to be now uh will continue
from the EU side thank you yes what we
see already what we experience is that
the momentum is already there um so the
atrocious war that Russia Unleashed
against Ukraine of course has created an
enormous push forward because uh it is
very clear uh the neighborhood our
neighborhood has to choose um where they
want to go um and the Western Balkans um
Georgia mova and Ukraine have very
clearly chosen they want to join the
European Union and this gave a momentum
and an impetus to those countries it is
remarkable um if you see if you look
into the report and you see the list of
reforms achieved it shows the
determination and the steadfastness that
is behind the political will and the
will of the population and the people to
move towards the European Union um and
also for us it is a very important
moment because we know that these
country are our European family we want
them in the European Union there's work
to be done but we are very clear about
what our aim is and uh therefore uh I I
also always call on all of us to use
this momentum now to uh finish the work
it's hard work still ahead of us but we
are on a very good tra trajectory and
this momentum should be
used
atin thank you Austin palai from U El
Croatia I have a question on covo the
only country now that doesn't have at
least recommendations even for candidate
status uh out of 10 that are in the
package so uh when you visited the
region you said that Serb should uh make
a de facto recognition of Koso this is a
statement also by the leaders of three
biggest EU member states what's are your
uh what's are your expectations for
Kosovo because Kosovo cannot count only
in the undefined European path without
the clear perspective of becoming a
candidate country thank you I think it
is important for
Kosovo um that has a very uh clear goal
also to join the European Union that we
are very clear also what we expect from
Kosovo um and that the country can
deliver we have discussed when I was in
the region um the implementation of the
draft statute that Kosovo um has gotten
for uh the
municipalities um and this
implementation would be a big step
forward it's in the interest of Kosovo I
also think that
um if we look at Kosovo and Serbia it is
important for us that we give each
country its unique possibility to move
forward towards the European Union so
not to tie too much both together
because the incentive is much more
positive if the question that we ask is
what is your
contribution um of by to move towards
the European Union what are your
activities
and that we emphasize the country's
genuine contribution to their on their
path toward the European Union you want
to add something one one sentence um I
think it is also very important to see
that uh yes there is an application for
membership uh put forward by Kosovo it
is in the council and the council has
not an opinion on it we are ready to
provide the opinion it is not my task to
interpret the position of the council or
the member states but our feeling is um
and you can also read this in our report
is that for Kosovo the European
path is coming through a successful
dialogue yes please please present
yourself you need to take the mic
no right next to you there's a
mic and push the button and wait until
it's read ahuh
okay first of all thank you for um
recognizing moldova's effort to became a
full State EU member and our question is
if one of the U members uh countries
doesn't not uh vote
in in the upcoming Summit for um uh the
open of negotiations so what are the
next steps for Moldova and does
it thank
you so um I think it's very important
I'm very confident uh that uh mova will
move on because uh your track record
moldova's track record is impressive
under very difficult circumstance an es
you are deeply strengthening and
reforming your country and uh we are
speaking about a merits based process
here are the merits of mdova uh that we
uh have to acknowledge and this is uh
what we're speaking all about therefore
I'm not fixing it on a date a marit
based process um does not is not fixed
to a date but you can be faster or you
can be slower and mova is showing what a
fast progress
looks
like
Runo
British sorry about that um as as you
said um uh history is calling um there's
a real surge um in the
aspirations um of the neighborhood of
Ukraine mova um to join the EU you said
that ukrainians and the movans in very
very difficult circumstances have done a
lot of homework 90% um for ke um that's
pretty impressive um but what about the
European side and what message have you
got to European governments who've got
quite a lot of homework uh to do
themselves when do you want to see that
homework
completed so indeed it is impressive to
see um that the countries that are um we
discussed here on the podium um all have
understood the call or heard the call of
History um and that is that you have to
choose
um you want democracy and
prosperity or you want uh an
authoritarian regime and dependence of
uh the judicial system you want uh to
join the European Union then there are
certain steps to be taken but we also
have the discussion of course in the
European Union because democracy it
we're never done with the work for
democracy we have always to keep up the
good work and always make sure that
democracy is alive and working and this
is a principle of values values are
Universal but the question is whether we
live them if we live them then it is
connected to our to our discussions at
home to our input uh in uh creating the
necessary legal framework um so
democracy is something that you have to
earn every single day now more focused
on the accession pro process um it is
very good that we also have started the
discussion
internally what does this mean for the
European Union and its structures and
this shows that we are very serious
about enlargement we're not only asking
the countries that want to join the
European Union um to undergo reforms and
to perform towards the European Union
but we are also asking ourselves what do
we have to do to be ready for an
enlargement by countries that are
mature next to joani yeah
yeah you wanted to ask a question no not
Javan next to you yes sorry I don't know
your first
name
for Okay Okay
cool so um
there
[Music]
for
r
um actually um we We Know by
exper We Know by experience that this
process can take
um well it is a process that is taking
forever so basically I would like to
understand how to make sure that this is
not about uh creating
false warning about this and I'm
thinking about Portugal and since I'm
talking about Portugal um let me ask you
also this question um are you aware or
are you surprised by the fact that the
Prime Minister Costa um uh quit uh
yesterday and if you talked to each
other and um most most um the most
important thing is do you see a risk
here for the implementation of the RF in
Portugal so we follow uh the news uh
from Portugal and it is now up to the
National authorities to
investigate um I think if we've
discussed a lot now the length of
accession negotiations or the process of
accession
um perhaps it's worse to look uh at the
countries that joined already the
European Union and there you see that um
the time period they needed to join the
European Union is very different and it
depended very much on uh the activities
a country developed and the speed it
made with the reforms so once again um
stating that it is a merit merits based
process implies
um you can speed up if you want to and I
think the last 20 months have shown that
a lot of countries that want to join the
European Union have heard this call they
have intensified the reform they have
sped up the reform process um and they
have strengthened their institutions not
all of them but the vast majority is
following the call of History uh it's in
their hand but it's in our
interest
J
weour I can do it in
[Music]
English
perhaps you start first
yes well also a bit uh responding to the
previous question um what you see
proposed today should also contribute
accelerating uh the whole enlargement
process and this is why for example the
growth plan is going to be fundamental
but as the President also said this is a
merit-based process so there are things
we cannot do instead of the candidate
countries it is their it is their work
that counts their work is the basis of
any enlargement now on the uh on the
institutional reforms yes uh the
institutional reforms are discussed in
the council but if there is one message
I think coming through is that uh first
of all there is no there is no
conditionality between enlargement and
institutional reforms the second is that
uh the EU is fit for enlargement with
the current set of treaties and with a
current set of rules and we should be
able uh to enlar large and welcome new
member states even on the basis uh of
the current treaties yes one can always
think about how to improve how to
further evolve but this is not because
of enlargement this is because we want
to improve our European Union so these
are two separate discussions and we
should keep them separate perhaps um if
we have
the topic of speed again this gives me
the opportunity to EMP emphasize um the
second proposal today um that has been
adopted by the commission that is the
growth plan and I want to emphasize what
you already said um
commissioner what we're doing here is
exceptional because we know by
experience from uh former enlargement
rounds that the miracle of prosperity
came with joining the EUR uh the single
Market um we saw in the accessing
countries the countries that joined a
huge rise in living standard and it was
also beneficial for our internal market
and therefore we are already starting
this process now with the growth plan it
is exceptional that we propos to say we
open our single Market in seven
important sectors for you um the Western
Balkans we expect you to also open among
you the common re regional market if you
only open the common regional market it
is a boost of 10% for their GDP but
joining also our single Market already
now could double their economies in one
in the next decade um and for that we of
course say we need a Level Playing Field
you have to be competitive so we
accompany that with reforms that you are
doing plus investment and this is a huge
step forward that we take already now we
do not wait till there is the final
decision of accession the political
accession but we already open the doors
of economic prosperity and joining the
single market and enlargening for also
for our single Market businesses the
market towards the common regional
market in the western
Balkans thank you Philip R on
intera
[Music]
we
Russia's goal was to wipe Ukraine off
the map if Russia would have succeeded
you can imagine what that would have
meant for our
security it is good
that
Russia's strategic goals Russia failed
on its strategic
goals um on the
contrary Ukraine as a nation is stronger
than ever
before um and this shows how important
it is to stabilize the Ukrainian
democracy to stand by them and to make
sure that um they will overcome this
massive aggression and uh the War
Unleashed by Russia against Ukraine if
you take the Wider Circle of countries
that want to join the European Union as
I think we both said at the beginning of
this press conference um this is a
decisive time the countries have to take
make choices and very clearly to say
which side they are choosing and it is
very clear also when you travel through
the region and the countries that want
to join the European Union we are
reporting on today
they also are very clear that they want
to join the European Union because they
see the difference there are several
countries trying to interfere in that
process but for us is to keep up the
good work and to give them the strength
they need uh on their path forward
towards the European
Union okay thank you very much that
brings us to the end of the press
conference thank you there will be a
technical briefing following this
Testament thank
you
e
[Music]